we've briefly looked at graph
isomorphism in the context of digraphs
and it comes up an even more fundamental
way really for simple graphs where the
definition is a bit simpler so let's
just look at this graph abstraction idea
and how isomorphism connects with it
this is an example of two different ways
of drawing the same graph that is here's
a 257 and there's 257 it's connected
directly to 122 as here and also 257 is
connected to 99 as here and if you check
it's exactly the same six vertices in
exactly the same seven eight edges but
they're just drawn differently so we
don't want to confuse a drawing of a
graph like these two with the graph
itself the graph itself consists of just
the set of nodes and the set of edges
and if you extracted that from these two
diagrams you would get the same set of
nodes in the same set of edges so same
graph different layouts but here's a
case where it's really the same layout
you can see these two pictures if you
ignore the labels are exactly the same
with the two grays and the two grays and
the red and red the difference now is
that I've renamed the vertices so we've
assigned different labels to those
vertices and the connection between the
two graphs now this graph with vertices
which are integers in this graph with
vertices that are the names of people is
that they are isomorphic and but I some
more fizz amines is that all that
matters between two graphs are their
connections and so graphs with the same
connections among the same number of
vertices are said to be isomorphic and
more say more precisely two graphs are
isomorphic when there's an edge
preserving matching between their
vertices matching meaning ejection
between their vertices and edges Erving
means that where there's an edge on one
side there's an edge between the
corresponding vertices on the other side
look at an example here are two graphs
and I claim that they are isomorphic on
the Left we got a bunch of animals dog
pig cow cat and on the right we have a
bunch of animal foods hey corned beef
tuna and it's a hint on how we're gonna
do the matching so I'm going to tell you
that the dog vertex on the Left
corresponds to the beef vertex on the
right so I'm defining a function of
ejection from the vertices on the left
in blue to the vertices on the right in
red and F of dog is beef
likewise F of cat cats eat tuna I'm
gonna map cat to tuna and continuing for
the remaining two vertices I'm gonna map
cow to hey which is what they eat and
pig to corn which is frequently what's
fed to pigs okay so this is a bijection
I'm you know it's a perfect
correspondence between the four vertices
on the left and the four vertices on the
right but I have to check now that the
edges are preserved what does that mean
well let's do an example there's an edge
on the left between dog and pig that
means that there should be an edge on
the right between where they go to the
so there ought to be an edge between
beef and corn because that's where dog
and pig go and indeed there's an edge
there so that part's good and you can
check the others the other thing that we
have to check on the left is since the
edge preserving is an if and only if
there's an edge on the right if and only
if is the edge on the left that's the
same as saying there's no edge on the
left if and only if there's no edge on
the right so let's check non edge is on
the left there's no edge between cow and
pig and indeed cow goes to hay and pig
goes to corn and sure enough there is no
edge on the right between hay and corn
and you can check the remaining cases
these two graphs are isomorphic and then
that function f is in fact the edge
preserving projection so stating it
again
an isomorphism between two graphs G 1
and G 2 is a bijection between the
vertices V 1 of G 1 in the vertices V 2
G toe
with the property that there's an edge
UV in G 1 and E 1 edge if and only if f
of U F of V is an edge in the second
graph in E 2 and it's an if and only if
that's edge preserving so if there's an
edge here there's an edge there if
there's no ledge on the left there's no
edge on the right and that's the
definition that's worth remembering um
it's basically the same as the a digraph
case except in the digraph case the
edges have a direction so there's it
wouldn't be an edge from u to V if and
only if there's an edge from F of u to F
of V but since we don't have to worry
about direction in the simple case the
the definition gets slightly simpler um
what about not an isomorphism how do you
show the two graphs are not isomorphic I
can show you the two graphs are
isomorphic by simply telling you what
the bisection between their vertices is
and then it becomes a simple matter of
checking whether the edges that should
be there are there or not how do you
figure out the two graphs are not
isomorphic that there isn't any by
ejection that edge preserves edges well
for a start these both have four
vertices so it's pasta perfect there are
lots of my ejections between the four
vertices on the left and the four
vertices on the right why isn't there an
edge preserving one well if you look at
the graph on the left it's actually got
two vertices of degree two marked in red
here there's a degree two vertex there's
a degree two vertex and on the right
every vertex is degree three if you
check now one of the things that
properties of isomorphism is that the
the edges that come out of the red these
two edges have to correspond to two
edges that come out of wherever it's
mapped to so a degree two vertex can
only map to a degree two vertex there
aren't any that's a proof that there
can't be an isomorphism between the two
graphs so in general the idea is that
we're looking at properties that are
preserved by isomorphism this is almost
like a state machine invariant kind of
idea so a property is
preserved by isomorphism means that if
two graphs if if graph one has the
property and graph one is isomorphic to
graph two then graph two has the
property and clearly if there's a
property that's preserved by isomorphism
and one graph has it and the other graph
doesn't have it that's a proof that they
can't be isomorphic so what are some of
these properties that are preserved by
isomorphism well the number of nodes
clearly there's got to be a by ejection
so they have to have the same number of
nodes they have to have the same number
of edges for similar reasons because the
edges are preserved an edge on one side
corresponds to an edge on the other side
other things that matter is we've just
sort of made this argument that the
degrees are preserved as a consequence
of the preserving of the edges and all
sorts of other structural properties are
going to be preserved by isomorphism
like for example the existence of
circular paths and distances between
vertices and things like that those will
all be properties that are preserved by
isomorphism so that gives you a hook on
trying to figure out whether or not two
graphs are or are not isomorphic but in
general there will be if you've got a
graph with a few hundred or thousand
vertices there are an awful lot of
potential by ejections between them to
check and the question is how do you do
it it's a huge search that it can't
really be effectively done exhaustively
so what you look for is properties that
are preserved by isomorphisms that give
you a guide so for example if the vertex
if the graph on the left happens to have
a degree 4 vertex and that degree 4
vertex is adjacent to a degree 3 vertex
then the adjacency of a degree 4 and a
degree 3 is a typical property that's
preserved by isomorphism so you know for
sure that if there's gonna be a
bijection between the first graph and
the second graph this pair of adjacent
vertices of degree 4 and degree 3 can
only map to another pair of adjacent
vertices in the second graph that also
have degrees 4 and 3 so that will cut
down in
normally the number of places that this
given vertex can map to in the other
graph and it gives you a some structure
to use to try to narrow down the search
for the number of isomorphisms and and
where the isomorphism is and whether or
not it exists so being having a degree
for Jason to a degree 3 for example is a
typical property that's preserved under
isomorphism
but even so um if I give you two very
large graphs and these are actually
extracted graphs from some communication
network an image of them it's very hard
to tell whether or not they're
isomorphic well you could guess because
of course we took the same picture and
copied it twice but if there was some
subtle difference between these two like
I erased one edge somewhere in the
middle of that mess how would you figure
out that the two graphs we're not
isomorphic in that case and the answer
is that like these np-complete problems
there is no known procedure to check
whether or not two graphs are isomorphic
that is guaranteed to be efficient and
to run in polynomial time on the other
hand there are technical reasons that
technical properties that says that
graph isomorphism is not one of these
np-complete problems unless P equals NP
or something like that and so that's one
distinguishing characteristic of this
problem the the important one is that as
a matter of fact in practice there are
some really good isomorphism programs
around that will in in many cases figure
out given two graphs whether or not they
are isomorphic in time that's
approximately the size of the two graphs
so pragmatically graph isomorphism seems
to be a manageable problem although
theoretically you but you can't be sure
that these efficient procedures that
work most of the time are going to work
always well known procedures in fact
blow up exponentially on some example or
another